I'm comfortable with you know taking a
sort of standardized graphic that the
Prime Minister used himself many has
used himself many many times in recent
months uh and years to highlight
policies to highlight how one of his own
policies isn't isn't working and one of
his own uh things that he's responsible
for the criminal justice system in this
country isn't isn't isn't working and so
it's it's taken from from that it's like
a it's what you do in in sort of
political uh campaigning it won't be to
everybody's uh taste but what's the
important issue here is What Lies
Beneath that which I think would be of
of real importance to to your viewers
which is that we do have serious
criminals now in this country almost
almost routinely uh getting uh more
lenient custodial sentences and they
would otherwise do because the system is
creaking at the knees